ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show giannis pappas there's a
special that is on youtube that you have
to watch it's going to come up right now
the hilarious stand-up comedian the the
pride
of greece
giannis pappas is called mom
love
and it's on youtube and you gotta watch
it it's all about transgender
people the whole thing it's an hour
of what your take
on the trans community yeah because it's
just because
no one else has done it yet yeah it's
not nobody's covered it so i really want
to delve into it
it's smart yeah it's good yeah and uh no
that's a joke
yeah it's about
ma what is it mom love what is that
about mom love and i think your fans are
really gonna love this special timothy
sure i think they're gonna love it
absolutely mom love is uh it's the last
joke in the special and it's essentially
saying that underneath everything we've
gotten out of balance there's too much
empathy there's too much you have mom
love and dad love
mom loves you unconditionally right dad
loves you
the way barely barely right based on how
you do conditionally right you do good
dad loves you a little more the way the
world will love you and there's too much
mom love there's too much empathy and
like we've talked about before tim
empathy is infinite there's no
end to empathy so dad love dad love his
condition dude it's conditional like
when my dad got divorced and lived with
his brother for two years and called me
once every two months
that's conditional love conditionally
right yeah okay he loves you
conditionally
yeah yeah he loves you a little bit more
now that you're doing good
yeah when you're living with dusty dodge
not so much yeah no when i was living on
a couch in hal's kitchen he was you know
he people said how's your son he goes i
have a son yeah he goes wait who which i
don't know if i have one yeah
so that's interesting so that's the
whole special and uh it's very funny
i've seen you do the hour live
you got to check it out it's on
youtube.com
[Music]
youtube network it's free
yeah and it's for your viewing pleasure
it costs a share
i'm trying to do that as an advertising
byline because i'm working on my
marketing right it costs a share share
it share it share it if you like it yes
be socialist about it i know some of
your listeners like communism we've got
we got we run a real spectrum here yeah
but from the hard left to the hard right
yeah
and uh so that's good those are the
interesting people though those are the
fun people those are the fun but you
don't want to go to dinner who's someone
who's nuanced no you want you want
somebody who's really gonna yeah it's
gonna bring it yeah yeah yeah i mean
obviously you know this will be you know
everybody in america
for the next few months and and and
since this shooting in texas is going to
talk about guns yeah this is going to be
uh or maybe not
or maybe that's over but
uh it's guns food and safety yeah guns
guns are a
they're they're out there
and
i think personally
that even some of the kids who were
killed
in texas if you brought them back they
would still be pro-gun
[Laughter]
that's my position like if you had a if
the ghost of one of them came back yeah
they would still be programmed because
it's it's
it's a right well and so
yeah in texas and florida all you have
to know
is all you gotta do is ask the guy like
were you scared a little bit for your
life and yeah i was frightened right
these kids were going to hurt me right
and then he stood his ground he stood on
his personal ground yeah yeah
you know you've been shot i have been
shot i have that unique experience you
have the unique experience of being shot
you've told it a million times and no
one cares so we're not going to rehash
it no but if you haven't been shot i
recommend that it's fun it does
kind of uh it it wasn't bad for you
no luckily now the guy who shot you yeah
he's doing a one-man show
about shooting you well i i don't know i
don't know i haven't really checked it
out i haven't gone to the uh limited
opening but i don't know he did a
one-man show this is a fact at some
point he did a one-man show at some
point yeah this is how strong the desire
is for fame in this country
at one point the man who shot you
outside of a nightclub
got on a stage yeah and did a one-man
show
about the decision
to shoot you
yeah i don't know what it was about but
i know that it was in there somehow
because that was part of the reason i
think he got in trouble
finally someone said okay we got to take
your gun away and we got to put you away
so he didn't even get caught before he
did the one-man show no he did the
one-man show i think from prison i
believe i don't know too much about you
he was caught first yeah i i you know i
i tend not to have you reached out to
forgive him the way the pope
has forgiven people that have tried to
assassinate the party remember when the
guy shot the pope and then the pope
forgave him yeah well that happened have
you forgiven have you reached out to
this person to forgive them
for shooting you i don't blame him you
know yeah i don't blame him he was doing
god's bidding yeah
but have you have you ever
thought about him again or tried to say
no i no are you angry at him
no no i'm not angry at him so my whole
thing is this besides the fact that if
it wasn't for him i wouldn't have had
all those [ __ ] panic attacks and i
probably would have made it in this
business a long time ago no i'm not mad
at him and he was armenian how the [ __ ]
can you do that to your greek brother
you piece of [ __ ]
but you seem to have how bad is it
getting shot this is my question i mean
truly and this is a real uh thing here
you seem okay and it doesn't seem like
it inhibits you in any other area of
your life so are we overreacting
to gun violence perhaps
i think it's just part of american
culture baby i think it's part of life
yeah it's part of life i think it's part
of life and i think you know people
should start saying that i think
politicians should start saying
getting shot is part of life as opposed
to keep you there keep running away from
it and i go why don't you just kind of
brand it as a uniquely kind of american
experience
where people have the freedom to shoot
you you also have the freedom to maybe
shoot them you do if you're if you get a
little scared
it's a violent country it's a country
where there's a just
there's more of a chance that you might
lose your life
in places that typically people don't
lose their life right you know it's a
violent country you could be you could
just be looking at tomatoes trying to
pick out which ones are more ripe right
and the next thing you know there's a
war happening in aisle four right and
you just have to be prepared so i think
i think the solution is every single
person if you take that element away
this is my concern it gets boring that's
right yeah if you take the element away
of potentially a massacre
in a grocery store you never know when
the ussr north korea is gonna attack
your living room right so you have to be
armed with as many semi-automatic
weapons as possible now you're not an
anti-gun not no i'm not at all you
believe
that people it should be a little harder
to get to the tylenol it might yes that
might help but the argument is is that
it is a little hard to get because you
have to leave your house and drive
somewhere
that is the argument it's not you can't
postmate go to postmates and try to get
a gun you can
you can't get a postmates gun
well of all the issues that i checked
all the counties in florida good point
yeah of all the issues we talk about on
this show i never get more hatred
than when i suggest that guns might
should be harder to get this is the
the thing and i again i'm second
amendment i believe you should be able
to own a gun protect yourself things
like that the with the minute i have
said that gun should be a little harder
to get i get i get vicious hit and i
understand it to a degree because you
have people going let's get rid of cops
let's get rid of any type of enforcement
and then let's just hope that you don't
get killed well that's part of the fear
and it's an understandable fear because
when you look at what the left does they
start out with you can't say this you
can't do it and then they just keep keep
going
police reform and then the next thing
you know they're like let's get rid of
cops as an idea yeah and you're like so
that's what people are scared of they're
scared of that that you know a little
common sense gun control
metastasizes
into a complete a confiscation of your
weapons and some of the rhetoric is
naive when you see it going guns are bad
get rid of guns i mean what's this
obsession with gun it's like these uh
blanket statements that play some
morality on the actual object right and
it's like no it's not the gun guns are
depends on the context whether a gun is
good or bad so is it your contention
yeah and it's not guns that kill people
it's lack of body armor that does it's
you know what it is now let me let me be
honest about this particular shooting
a the cops did not go into this school
for a long time guy had a couple guy was
armed yes but you know is it your job as
a police officer to confront
that which is happening in the moment
depends on whether it's a rival school
from where your kid plays that's a great
point i never thought about that depends
on which i knit because it is so big
there in texas huge i never thought
about
what what football team they're gonna
play i never thought about that i didn't
even think about that
is it possible these guys are going you
know what maybe a few quarterbacks are
getting it in there
and our numbers are going up exactly
my question is because a lot of people
are saying
yuvaldi school shooter was in school for
up to an hour before law enforcement
broke into a room where he was
barricaded and killed him that seems
like a lot of time giannis well it's a
lot of time but you know it seems too
much the cops probably had to ask a lot
of permission from certain organizations
right you know do we have a couple
social workers here to talk to him first
and find out why he just talked him down
what happened what could what what kind
of institutions have failed him yes what
kind of system well you know the guy who
killed the 10 people in buffalo in the
grocery store the cops then he went to
go kill himself the cops are like no
don't yeah yeah let him do it yeah i
don't know what i mean yeah what are you
gonna do like no don't worry about it
you you made one mistake yeah we want to
find out why you did it you got your
whole life ahead of you come here give
me a hug
you're a good boy yeah um so to me it
feels like uh a quote here it's gonna be
within like 40 minutes or something
within an hour texas department of
public safety director steve mcgraw told
cnn's ed lavandera at news conference
the 18 year old shooter salvador ramos
was in a stand-over law enforcement
officers for about a half hour after
firing on students and teachers rep tony
gonzalez i mean here's the argument that
that pro-gun people make and this is an
interesting argument
guns are not new
school shootings are new
there is something mentally going on
where
we have a huge mental health crisis this
doesn't mean you should be able to get a
gun at 7-eleven
what i am saying is
there is something going on in the
culture i don't know what it is
i have a few ideas that is
it's a coarsening
potentially of
the culture in the sense that
we are creating perhaps
more violent sociopaths now
than we were then
yeah you got to get this kid into acting
classes early that's true because he he
posted a photo with eyeliner yeah and he
was kind of you know had some issues he
got bullied a lot
you just got to take that sociopathy and
and that it you got to put it in a place
where he can use it and it it it
benefits him that's a great point acting
entertainment politics yes you know
should we be identifying sociopaths at a
younger age and putting them on a path
to be our leaders
as opposed to killing children in a
school they can kill children in other
countries on our behalf absolutely it's
not about it we need some youth outreach
programs that identify these sociopathic
traits early and then put them on the
right track get them into a couple of
improv classes or how about this it's
like hey you don't feel good there's a
place for you there's a place for you
there's a place for you without empathy
there's a hundred percent a thing you
can do i don't know much about this guy
and um his name is salvador ramos he was
18 years old supposedly he was bullied
uh he wrote three disturbing messages on
facebook just uh minutes before the
messinger a massacre warning of the
carnage to come quote i'm gonna shoot my
grandmother salvatore ramos wrote about
30 minutes before his rampage on
facebook
how many people liked that that sounds
like something i would have written
nobody knows he's serious
and no one knows you're serious if i saw
him gonna shoot my grandmother i'd i
like that it's hilarious but not now
it's not they just the bots and whatever
writing minutes later listen to this
ramos made good on his vow writing
minutes later that he'd quote shot his
grandmother his last message foretold
his final act of unspeakable violence
i'm going to shoot in elementary school
he wrote about 15 minutes before he
arrived on camera i hate dealing with
this issue in a funny way it is a comedy
show because it is a a
an unspeakable
tragedy people's kids were killed it is
the most evil act i can imagine
um
it is the uh um
um
it
i think it is the most evil act
it's the most out there it's
premeditated it's evil here's the thing
we live in a country
have you seen nikki glazer's instagram
lives where she's she's gonna do a song
about this which she does a guitar yeah
that is also premeditated but
i don't i think this is worse
it's evil yeah and
there it is too easy to get a gun
and this type of stuff is is is crazy so
i don't want to i'm not trying to
minimize it but it is weird to be a
comic and do a show where we're you know
we're having fun absolutely we have to
do our job i mean it's the most
horrendous thing ever it you can't get
more evil than this also you know the
what happened in buffalo you know just
because it's evil no it's evil it's like
this one brings out the [ __ ] but it's
like you know there were randomly
targeted black people's horrible as well
absolutely insane but the thing is we
live in a country where we're so fame
obsessed and i think when these
sociopaths feel like that fame is out of
their reach right they go for infamy
when something's this premeditated
there's no assassins or premeditated
murderers who don't want the attention
right tension in this country is
currency so this guy's going like uh it
seems like a lot of work for me to you
know become an actor whatever it is on
sports sports to find myself in the
business world yeah come up with an app
so i'll settle for infamy so i'll settle
for being remembered that's the only
thing people respect in this country is
how someone's famous it doesn't matter
how they i yeah i made the news yeah
they're looking at all these other stuff
they're looking at our culture and going
like hey man people love serial killer
documentaries they love all these people
who do horrible things and then they
they celebrate them the news constantly
you know uh plays into that reptilian
part of our brain and scares us
and does oh this is this story happened
and they replay the horror over and over
and over again like the will smith slap
you know it's just right they they play
it over and so it's like hey man i want
to be i want to be known for some it's a
real nihilistic uh tour de force in
infamy
i took the helix quiz and i was matched
with the model mattress because i wanted
something that felt
firm and i sleep on my side i move
around all night
and i have night terrors
i get up in the middle of the night and
i run around
literally have night time
and people literally have night terrors
in their sleep
i'm sorry to be insensitive
if you're looking for a mattress take
the quiz you order the mattress that
you're matched to and if the mattress
comes right to your door ship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2021 by gq and wired
magazine helix has been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving sleep just go to
helix.com timd take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix even has
financing options and flexible payment
plans to get a great night's sleep so a
great night's sleep is never far away
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
helix
sleep.com
tim d
that is helix sleep.com tim d
it's a huge upgrade i love helix i sleep
on it you sleep on it it's a great
upgrade i've never been happier in my
life with a mattress than helix because
i could personally customize the exact
matches for me and that's what you need
ladies and gentlemen you know what i've
always said about expressvpn expressvpn
is very important right now all these
companies private uh contractors
government they're all trying to steal
your information everybody you are not
safe in your own home they are coming
for you they're coming in through your
computer to get you
so
how do you do it why does everyone need
a vpn every time you connect to an
encrypted network in cafes hotels
airports your online data is not secured
any hacker on the same network can gain
access to you and steal your personal
data passwords financial details etc
what if you're an australian you want to
watch american netflix you need a vpn it
doesn't take much technical knowledge to
hack someone just some cheap hardware is
needed a smart 12 year old can do it
your data is valuable baby why use
expressvpn it's an encrypted tunnel it's
super secure it's easy to use it works
on all devices you use it i use it
everybody yeah
i love expressvpn secure your online
data today by visiting expressvpn.com
tim dillon that's e-x-p-r-e-s vpn
that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com tim dillon you can
get an extra three months free
expressvpn.com tim dillon
expressvpn.com do it right now it
supports the show giannis what do you
think about it absolutely absolutely
expressvpn everybody get it
onlookers urged police to charge into
texas school this is interesting because
you have cops standing outside
people are heckling them going get in
there yeah
um
and they're not doing it that's like
that's like a sports fan at a game like
why did you do it it's like dude you're
sitting there drinking a beer
you know yeah but i i don't know why
they're not going in there for an hour
that's crazy honest that is crazy that's
crazy it is crazy that's crazy quote go
in there go in there nearby women
shouted at the officer's suit after the
attack began
said juan here's the deal if the cops
are going to run around and go we have
the most dangerous job in the world
which is statistically not true not even
in the top ten it is a dangerous job but
it's not the most dangerous job in the
world per capita statistically it's very
dangerous in certain areas for sure if
that is going to be the party line you
got to go into the school
while this guy is shooting but you can't
stand outside for an hour
that seems to be crazy and i know
there'll be 19 cops that'll message me
and go no you don't understand anything
exactly you have to wait you have to
understand it's protocol there's things
that need to be done but it's not it's
not protocol if it's a black kid walking
down the street
but his protocol if it's in a
so my old thing is the women are
shouting at the cops go in there
go in there
they're shouting
um upset the police officers were not
moving in
um a few of the other bystanders were
like let's charge into the school
he goes let's just rush in because the
cops aren't doing anything like they're
supposed to more could have been done
they were unprepared
minutes earlier carranza this is a guy
had watched the salvador ramos crashed
his truck into a ditch outside the
school grabbed his ar-15 semi-automatic
rifle and shot two people outside a
nearby funeral home who ran away
uninjured shot at two people
officials say he encountered a school
district security officer outside the
school though they were conflicting
reports from authorities on whether the
man exchanged gunfire after running
inside he fired on two arriving ivaldi
police officers who were outside the
building said texas department of public
safety spokesperson travis considine the
police officers were injured after
entering the school ram was charged into
one classroom and began to kill he
barricaded himself by locking the door
and just started shooting children and
teachers that were inside the classroom
um
absolutely
insane
we got to take this conversation from
the media and activists yeah and it
really has to
people need to sit down and find some
solutions right that aren't you
without shouting these utopian slogans
that's right they're going like guns are
evil we should have no guns or the other
side going don't take them we got to
stop that right and this is there's no
perfect solution there's mitigation can
we please
mitigation [ __ ] mitigate
can we make it a little less
mitigation babies
mitigation baby
what a beautiful word mitigation because
you do need to find the happy medium you
gotta have to find the common ground
yeah you have to find the place where
everybody is
okay yes and happy
the the the most uh you know the best uh
for the most you gotta find the thing
that works for everybody you gotta find
something that's a little
less convenient for the mexican cartels
right who gets supplied with all their
weapons from us they do buy our guns
that's where they get but that's an
honor
it's quid pro quo there's something nice
about
salvador ramos was angry that he did not
graduate texas neighbor said how dumb do
you have to be to not graduate a texas
high school
i mean can you you can't graduate at
texas high school yeah
classmates of the 18 year old who
murdered at least 19 children and two
teachers are due to attend a graduation
ceremony on friday may 27th ramos is
fury over his lack of academic success
sparked a fight with his grandmother
shortly before he shot her i kind of get
that and drove to rob elementary school
to embark on the killing spree so this
guy's he's a troubled guy he's unhappy i
would say so he's not smart psychopathic
he's psychopathic he's not smart the
grandma goes you're an idiot he gets
upset
now he goes and buys the air 15 ben on
his 18th birthday he bought two of those
and he goes two
just just in case north korea invades
our home yeah he gets two ar-15s
on the 18th birthday he probably said to
the cash register he's probably said i'm
gonna need another one so i can reload
when i'm shooting up to school and they
probably went like that's your freedom
that's your business
that's your business i'm not that's
freedom of expression i don't need to
know all of that i don't know you are
free to be free
i don't need to know all of that it's
not my business when you walk out here
with these two ar-15s you do whatever
you damn well please i mean it doesn't i
think whether you see one
where
people reading in the library well then
you better you need these to defend
yourself against trans people you might
need three guns maybe three i'm not
gonna ask maybe you're using them for a
science project i don't need to know it
doesn't matter at least one additional
kid died uh directly because the cops
were incompetent somebody said when the
cops come the cop said
the cops said yell if you need help and
one of the persons in my class said help
the shooter overheard and he came in and
shot her oh my god yell if you need help
somebody yelled help and then the the
guy goes in and shoots her i i mean i
gotta be honest with you and i'm not
trying to neg the cops here but this
this is not the most this isn't a crack
squad of geniuses out there can we just
say that like in a school where it's
being shut up they go just start yelling
yeah yeah help that'll be good i just
don't think it's a job right now that
anyone wants anyone wants and yes and
cops are scared to do it
yeah for sure it's like they always are
they're under the microscope but in
texas that's less true it's less true
it's less true and there's not a rage
against the cops in texas right
especially in this scenario right where
we need them to spring into action we
need them to go into a school that's
being shut up this isn't a highly
controversial thing right um so that is
tragic
uh and unfortunate but there is a happy
there is somewhere to get to where maybe
guns are harder to get we're an 18 year
old can't purchase two ar-15s without a
waiting period or a background check or
something like that well and you need to
make it you know the problem is and you
know the state's rights you know the
smaller government people
they hate the federal government but it
has to be uniform if you're going to
have a country you can't go into you
can't have it so you go into indiana and
you can buy a resold gun at a gun show
and all these loopholes and then and
then you know go sell them in chicago
you can't go from another state and get
an easy one and then travel to you got
to make it all the same right you got to
make it all the same because we don't
have close borders yet between our
contiguous states yeah so it's like it's
got to be the same everywhere which
small government people states rights
people hate so it'll always be a problem
it'll never be solved it's just gonna be
part of our great american tradition
football
cheese fries buffalo wings and murder
of children yes so the nra is going to
gather in houston days after the texas
school massacre and there's going to be
some protests people are going to be
upset
about uh this and the nra
yeah 55 000 people are showing up yeah
it's a big convention in houston for the
nra what are they gonna what are the
themes this year they'll probably all be
caring
it's gonna be i tell you right now it's
a tough one
it's a tough one as a convention goes
it's a tough one you know they're gonna
get out they're gonna dress it they're
gonna go people want a limit they're
gonna be like he's a good guy with a gun
oh well that that didn't work in buffalo
yeah because the guy had body armor we
need more body armor right people we
need is it wrong to say kids should go
to school and body armor is it wrong to
think that fashion designers need to up
their game that's right start
incorporating
defense into their style tommy hilfiger
body armor that's right hey tory burch
wake up wake up we need military gear
for most people body armor bulletproof
clothing body armor
if you put kids in little bulletproof
vests what's the then everything's fixed
is it not cute it's very cute if you put
kids in kevlar
is there a problem with that i'm you
know i'm seriously asking if we're not
going to ban the guy like how nuts will
it get that's a solution that's the
solution a lot of times the fashion is
very uh environment specific you go to
miami it's like light colors you live in
america it should be body armor and
bulletproof
this is interesting so this is uh read
this tweet then for us so this was uh
the gunman bought the weapons using the
attack shortly after his 18th birthday
and the gun store he posted receipts
from tweeted this that day this was
their app train up a child in the way he
should go and when he was old he will
not depart from it and you see a
child with an ar-15 this is from daniel
defense and they've locked their account
and uh they're a small weapons
manufacturer out of georgia
the mel uh the military industrial
complex in our country
it's a baby it's not a problem it's a
baby who's doesn't know anything yeah
with it with a with a gun with a toy in
texas yeah an ar-15 yeah to train up a
child in the way he should go and when
he's old he will not depart from it now
notice he's not reading a book
he's not playing sports
notice he's not even worshiping it at a
church
he is sitting on the floor what is that
ben is that an ar-15 uh it looks like
some sort of air filter he's sitting on
the floor with like an assault rifle
it's a gun that works really well yeah
whatever it is ar-15 or not yeah
whatever it does it yeah
whatever it is it's efficient
um it's interesting that they tweeted
that on the day
an 18 year old murdered a bunch of kids
yeah at the very least it's a marketing
snafu
[Laughter]
at the very least yeah
yeah
well they won't a lot the people who
defend this won't say it is right it'll
all be blamed on mental health right
mental health and that's not and it's
not wrong but
also those people are not saying let's
give people health care that's never
their second point no they never go we
got a mental health crisis we should
have uh health care right that's never
point number two right and also it's
like you know i i used to work in that
field you know it's like you don't walk
into a psych ward and get shot right i
mean
there's got to be a gun in their hands
my mother is mentally ill she's very
mentally ill she's never killed anyone
right so i do think that it kind of
it's it's a weird way it shits on
mentally ill people right to say that
they're all violent murderers right i
don't believe yes i don't think anyone
who kills someone's mentally well
i think that you know but in the group
of mentally ill people there's a small
percentage of them that are violent
and you know it people have been getting
more and more it's almost like this
50-year diet of poison food
drugs booze
high stress
paranoid media has finally gotten into
people's heads yeah and that seems to be
maybe an issue i mean it's like we've
spent 50 years poisoning the population
getting them hooked on drugs so that
they can perform their uh tasks at work
stressing them to the point of nervous
breakdowns and apparently they're not
able to really um raise their children
uh in a way that prevents them from uh
mass murder yeah this is a multi-faceted
issue there's a lot of things going on a
lot of things going on and even in this
very reasonable podcast we're doing the
rage will not stop the rage in the
comments will not the first comment
would be i couldn't get through it yeah
i did why don't they understand there
are background checks i had to wait five
minutes to get that gun
the second comment will be like the gun
stuff wasn't so bad but tim no guess
right right
get him out of there
and folks by the way we're not doing
that a lot this summer we're not doing a
lot of stuff because i'm not that upset
about the gun thing
here's your reality i don't even like
them devin and i to come and sit here
who i love yeah and they don't really
speak right and that works and you know
you we like and there's a few people
like boy it's not a guest show right
it's never going to be a guest show
right and we're never going to make it a
guest show i love how you got this chair
though for ray kumpf it's a ray
competition
this is like ray and i like right you
know here's the tight squeeze
podcasts are kind of ending
and this is the reality um people have
had enough
they've had enough of the same 20 people
talking about the same things
and that's why we've never gotten into
the guest model right nobody has
anything to say that matters and i don't
care if they do
and that's why we've never embraced a
model of gas and that's why we're
getting into the bullet defense fashion
line business we're going to start
arming uh children with kevlar
vast cute kevlar
thought about doing merch like tim
dillon show on body armor
oh but it's too expensive to produce
and it's too expensive for people to buy
yeah
do you ever get sad
can you talk into the [ __ ] microphone
you
you
do you ever get sad i'm always sad do
you ever feel
that things are not good
yeah when i read the news
it's a better help is a customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
better help life can be overwhelming and
many people are burned out without even
knowing it symptoms can include lack of
motivation feeling helpless or trapped
detachment fatigue and more
we associate burnout with work but
that's not the only cause any of our
roles in life can lead us to feel burned
down
and better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
it's about you
and people forget that they try to help
other people
but it's about you
because when you're better you can help
others
better help online therapy the tim dylan
show listeners getting ten percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com tim
d that's betterhelp.comd
have you used betterhelp i have yeah i
love it and what do you love about it i
love that it's always there for me when
i need it
what does that even mean ben
well it means i mean have you
articulate what that means have you ever
been to therapy
yes sometimes you can't get like a a
good slot because if you're like me i
kind of would always want it like last
minute and this i always got good slots
and what did you talk about with them uh
how i have feelings of like
worthlessness and uh but those are
justified
um it says breaking texas dps now say
there was no school police officer who
encountered or engaged the mass
uh shooter at robb elementary school the
shooter was not confronted before entry
and it appears he walked into the school
through an unlocked door
we got to lock the doors that seems
obvious to everyone involved the doors
of the school have to be locked you know
i showed up at my old school i was with
a friend this was years ago and i was
you know i thought i'd do like a little
homecoming like hey this is where i went
to school i thought i could walk down i
had no idea and this was years ago i had
no idea how like how shut down these
schools were it was all locked i knocked
on the door they were like hello excuse
me and through the glass i was like yeah
i went to school here i'm tim dylan yeah
i was on joe rogan we talked about bill
gates
and
they
they looked at me like the guy looked at
me like i was crazy showing up at a
school and now you know upon
further reflection i now i get it it
does seem crazy do you think uh though
because the glock doors inevitably
someone will get in you think at some
point what we need to do is have decoy
schools like saddam hussein palaces very
interesting the students are in a decoy
school right and then we have doubles in
the other schools right but it's gonna
get out which school is which well then
you gotta check you gotta keep moving
like what about if we educated kids
underground underground would be like
underground we have underground cities
we have underground military bonkers
right the kids don't need sunlight they
can certainly underground we can
recreate the conditions of uv light or
the military industrial complex will
make a clip out of this yeah everyone
arm up and don't leave
and just let delivery people deal with
it yes delivery people are the only
brave ones now yeah i mean i was talking
about that today somebody on instacart
delivered me two candles they had to
take that long walk
from the door to the wall to their car
in the walgreens parking lot depending
on the time of day in los angeles that
ain't nothing that's nothing you have no
idea what could happen on your way i
guarantee you an instacart or postmates
worker on the way to the car has met
their end yeah or release a new virus
for our own safety to get us back
indoors you just see a burrito fall to
the floor and then blood yeah because
that people that leave their houses now
really are the the most brave yeah and
it's gonna be it's the most brave people
they're the most brave people they're
they're outside teachers maybe are more
brave than cops now i mean teachers
teaching might be a more deadly job than
police you got to arm them yeah you got
to arm these kindergarten teams well
here's the deal in texas why didn't they
have guns i'm not even kidding like why
did they not have guns in texas like is
this all
the gunman's fault or can we lay a
little bit of blame on the teachers who
weren't carrying these [ __ ] moving from
california that's what it is you have a
bunch of liberal teachers moving from
california that don't have guns and
aren't focused on the defense of the
school and it's not just enough to have
guns again i i just want to focus right
we need body armor because the other guy
and that is what's being seriously
suggested yeah well you need body armor
because the guy's going to come if he's
got a bigger gun he's prepared he's
going right i watch a lot of
self-defense videos right the perp
always has the advantage right because
he's the one that comes in and goes
we're doing this right you have to go oh
[ __ ] we're doing this because you he he
has the element of surprise the element
is surprised and he may have an ar-15
those things are pretty efficient they
do their job so what we need is what
let's let's plan a salary we one student
we need one teacher at the chalkboard
handgun maybe
ready in the one hand then we need
another teacher so you're saying just a
teacher
pretty much all day
at the at the at the ready well you
don't know if the kid's got a gun so you
got to have one
facing the kids that's right and then
you have to have someone watching your
blind spot so we need another teacher a
teacher's eight if you will the
teacher's age they don't even need to
keep this door we just need two armed
people in each classroom one watching
the door one watching the windows ar15
is drawn
it's not a bad idea you have two we have
two people in the classroom they each
have an ar-15 out yeah and they really
and it's just got a fun way to quiet the
kids down too yeah quiet down
it's nap time yeah yeah now the kids
themselves may be armed because it's
their right yes
but
as long as you have an ar-15 you have
the advantage because their little hands
can't quite grasp or deal with the
pushback of an ar-15 yeah you can take a
few of them out if you need to if you
need to you'll get a few so if we if we
because now we're fine we need to live
in the last scene of a quentin tarantino
movie where everyone's pointing guns at
each other at all times we're finding
the common ground here and this is what
i want to stress so if you have a few
people in each classroom with ar-15s one
trained on the kids one on the door of
the classroom and one in the teacher
because you don't know what they're
going through oh it's a great point
because the teacher might flip out so
you need you need one kid marshall yes
in the class so a kid marshall with a
gun
who has a gun on the teacher
you need two teacher's aides
with ar-15s one at the door one at the
class yes
yes interesting yes it's not a bad idea
and you need school uniforms and those
uniforms are body armor
kevlar body armor uniform yes
ar15 at the kids ar15 at the teacher
ar15 at the door
problem solved not a big deal not a
tough way to live at all it's fine it's
totally comfortable and the most
important part reasonable right right
and people in other countries would
watch this and they would they would
think it's comedy but what it actually
is is a good plan it's a great smart
thought-out cogent plan it's not a bad
idea not at all yeah otherwise we're
going to be just relying on what we're
relying on now which i guess is chance
happenstance luck yeah
yeah because now it seems like a casino
a little bit if you send your kids to
school yeah no a little bit of a casino
even in supermarkets i would feel a lot
safer yes armed i would feel a lot safer
if the army was there while i got
lettuce
if the if the military could potentially
enforce a barrier around the supermarket
and check people as they went in yeah
we need military checkpoints at safeway
i don't think it's a bad idea i don't
think so put the military outside
supermarkets i don't think so at all and
you know that it will come into this
conflict i guess it's like the thing
that a lot of people are nervous of is
government overreach but this is is part
of this it doesn't seem the death and
destruction of mayhem doesn't seem to
bother people as much since the internet
people have kind of been desensitized to
this we do have a culture of people that
don't really care that a bunch of kids
died we do have a culture of people that
don't really care about death we have
made a generation of sociopaths
we and and i i wonder how much
technology's had to do with that i feel
like it's had a good amount to do it i
think also what's had something to do
with it is just the sheer
volume yeah
by of the horror of just how much it
happened that's right it's just teresa
neela that joke you can't care about
everything it's like putting out three
podcast episodes a week it's like it's a
lot right you get a little you get a
little
numb to it right it's a lot so it's like
how many are you gonna care for you
gotta you almost have to pick and choose
which one's gonna get you now right you
know right and and it's just it's um i
mean they happened like weeks i i think
i read i think the statistic and men can
look at 2022 so far there's been
hundreds how many mass shootings in 2022
hundreds now mass shootings defined as i
think any time more than four people are
shot yeah uh 214 200 so far and we are
in uh june we're in june
204 and what defines a mass shooting
i believe it's over four people in may
yes
i believe it's four the u.s has had uh
we're in may right sorry uh 214 mass
shootings so far this year
and defines a mass shooting i believe
is
for
people
shot now i don't know if that's the case
um
look guns are good if they're in the
right hands they're bad if they're in
the wrong hands we need to do something
to make sure that there's less in the
wrong hands and more in the right hands
whatever that is have added america four
or more deaths i was correct have at it
more
yeah more guns and better hands yeah
that's it right that's all there is to
it it's all there is to it it's got to
be harder than getting a prescription
for
uh you know whatever your doctor
prescribes right and it's but you know i
one of my friends uh uh you know little
brothers came to visit my house and like
uh
he's from the appalachians or whatever
and they make moonshine and it's a
different life it's a different life
it's just a different life yeah
and you know they find out if they find
a woman at the gas station they they
bring a new chain or in the back cabin
you know what i mean it's a different
life
it's a different life yeah and
i thought you i thought you'd hired him
to murder me yeah no he's not yeah you
know
it was a little terrifying
we had dinner with david spade he was
like cutting into the plate he was like
cutting into the plate like david spade
was staring at him like what the hell is
going on he's like cutting into the play
but my point is lovely kid my point is
that it's a different life
it's a different life yeah and his first
reaction after the school shooting was
like i you know they can't take my guns
because they left they you know that's
that's the thing
a lot of in other countries masculinity
is maybe defined by [ __ ] a hot woman
yeah but a lot of times we now our
masculinity kind of rests on the idea
that like
you or how you're if you have a phantom
war in your head that you're going to be
a part of one day yeah i'm not saying
you shouldn't have guns to defend
yourself i'm saying that like you go to
australia and you see a bunch of
good-looking people on the beach [ __ ]
each other yes they're not like where
are the ar-15s yeah but nobody in
australia that's like drunk hanging out
in the beach
none of them are like hey where are the
automatic weapons to really make this a
good time yeah you can't ignore the
cultural component to this like there is
and here's the thing about australia
i've said before they're white mangoes
so i'm not saying let's completely
emulate it's the mongoloids but but you
know it's like you see all these
hollywood people saying we got to do
something take away the guns we have to
do
some we got to get this regulation and
then those same people will be starring
in a movie right with mark wahlberg
called diving gun guy right so it's like
it's just the movies are like bank bank
or someone will assault someone who made
a joke at the oscars and they'll applaud
that person and they'll applaud that
person and cry for a speech yeah so i'm
i respect i'm saying people should be
able to own guns should be able to
defend themselves
um you know i i just feel like it is
it's [ __ ] horrible that this keeps
happening
and it doesn't seem to and let's show
any signs of abating at all at all and
it's just odd culturally yes that you
can have movies where people are being
[ __ ] executed
by the droves but if you show a little
bit of a penis
or a nipple people it's like outrageous
what is that it's a puritanical country
purity it's a puritanical we prefer
murder to sex that's well that's now
we're getting so now we're getting it
it's weird now we're getting it yeah i
mean you go watch a french movie they're
like [ __ ]
you see the in and out yeah we really
prefer murder to sex here we're kind of
a sexless culture yeah people just want
to eat and kill each other yes that's
what america's kind of become
and um i think we have to embrace it i
don't think we should i think we should
embrace what makes us unique it's what
makes us unique other countries like
having sex with each other yeah they
like hat you know i think it's it's for
us to just go to ihop armed is a
beautiful thing and our enemies maybe it
helps a little bit that they don't even
consider attacking us because they're
like they're killing each other we don't
have to invade them yeah perhaps but it
is very interesting the component of
this that's weird psychosexual in a
weird way like where it's kind of like
you know there is something to be said
for the fact that young men in america
right now are not
kind of socializing you know not all of
them but there's a sect of them that
like are finding it difficult to find
partners
and mates and they're not and it's
becoming difficult i'm sure it's
happening in other places as well but
some of those people are grabbing
weapons like that is something that some
of them do
they are
enraged i mean again all we heard after
9 11 was like it's a bad idea for men in
the arab world to not be near any women
and to be in these cults and to you know
to be sexually frustrated and to be
[ __ ]
you know like indoctrinated and now you
start to see
that we have
a similar vibe going on with a lot of
guys in america
that for whatever reason are just like
hey you know i'm having more fun with a
gun than a [ __ ] right it's not the only
no it's not
otherwise all these school shooters
would just be married men no and this
guy might have been uh this guy might
have been gay or trans or straight i
don't think it
truly matters there seems to be just a
wider issue yeah it really is there is
an issue where like i said like if you
show a p you can't even show a penis why
is there such a taboo about a penis you
can't show a vagina like why right
what's the big deal right but you can
show murder
without well you could also show like
cuties in netflix doc you have young
girls twerking yeah so in america you
could get away with it if it's
pedophilia pedophile you're a murderer
people in america hate
appropriate age sex right you hate it
they don't like consensus they hate it
appropriate it's either you if it's
either violence or [ __ ] children
that's all that they can handle yes or a
big mac yes
yeah but appropriate age sex is just
grotesque yeah it's weird people in
america there's no taboo it's not fun
it's our puritanical roots there's
something there a little bit yeah yeah
it really is and that's why the people
that rebel against it are like in san
francisco dressed up as leather dogs
being walked down the street alicia well
that's really not the answer either it's
just all a country of extremes
it's a country of extremes you go why
can't you just like why can't you have
regular sex
that's you know
somewhat irregular instead of just
having to dress up like a dog and be
walked down the street and pissed and
[ __ ] on and whipped and beaten to get
hot i mean people can't get off now
unless a woman's being waterboarded
choked thrown down the stairs yeah i
mean you know you you're kicking her in
the face like sex now has gotten
incredibly violent just so people can
come and you wonder
yeah in france or any of these places
you will see people just [ __ ] but
america it's like people need to get
choked they need to have their head
through the wall it's just yeah it just
makes you real cynical about humanity
that
it's one of the few things we have that
is good for you to come right there's no
consequences right it's not like doing
drugs whether you well now with roe v
wade there's gonna be some kind of
there's some conscience no there's gonna
be some consequences but i mean it's one
of those but it's also women what do you
have better to do than have the baby you
know what i mean like truly like the
reality is you think my mother didn't
want an abortion you don't think she
knew she had a fat gay cocaine addict
inside of her yeah here's the reality
i was born and she ignored me and took
me to wendy's and that's what you do as
a parent you just take your kid to
wendy's
um
you know so i mean
take your summer adventures to the next
level with the bespoke post and the new
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections
are you ever home janice you go i'd like
a box absolutely bespoke post partners
with small businesses and emerging
brands to try to bring you the most
unique goods every month what's cool
about this is you can start and stop
anytime you want but if somebody you
know is going away for college or
wherever they're moving and you want to
get them a cool present you can send
them a bespoke post box of awesome and
they'll take a quiz and they'll fill it
out and it'll say what they're into and
then bespoke post will just send them
really cool stuff every single month i
love it
you can get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code tim
dillon at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code tim dillon for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com code
tim dillon i mean what do you like about
box of awesome ben well there's a lot of
boxes i really like oh my god will you
tell us about some of them you [ __ ]
[ __ ] of course well that
that was very rude but um
but uh [ __ ] is a term of endearment and
empowerment yeah i guess you're right
that's exactly exactly right
ooh that's nice a knife and a bottle of
liquor yeah whoo
they put bullets in there yet yeah
i like the pancake box that's what they
sent me a griddle so i can make pancakes
on the go
dude i got this knife if i'm on a gas
station and i'm out of gas station i
need a a quick stack
what did you get a knife i got the knife
for uh i think it's for fishing i'm not
really sure but it's awesome sure all
the time in
i love box of awesome because there's
all kinds of different things in the box
and they come from small companies
and they need the help and we have used
these we've sent these to your relatives
we've sent these to your friends nobody
does more for their family than me
box of awesome dot com enter the card
tim dillon to check out that's box of
awesome dot com code tim dillon for 20
off your first box box of awesome dot
com code tim dylan
you know those days in your coffee shop
is out of cold brewing your air
conditioner breaks and you're trying to
go to the beach and there's zero parking
spots life can be hard good thing me
undies is here to help you take a break
from the hardships of the world and give
yourself a soft summer
when you're cocooned in the softest and
most breathable undies loungewear and
swimwear known to all humanity all your
problems will simply melt away
for example how are you planning on
relaxing with to the max while staying
cold this summer
meanders are great because they're cool
they use micro modal fabric you can stay
comfy and cool all summer long they have
super fun seasonal prints and tons of
styles
uh in uh to choose from in sizes x
through 4xl so you can go to the beach
bring the beach to your butt without
ever leaving your living room
do you like me undies i you i wear them
do you like me on these i wear them too
they're actually super comfortable yeah
they are they're soft stretchy and
sustainable
make it a soft summer with me undies
me undies has a great offer for my
lasagnas
forever
ready first time purchase you can get 15
off if you sign up for their free to
join membership you can apply that 15
off to their ready discounted membership
prices it's not great for jingle it's a
little wordy
to get 15 off your first order in a 100
satisfaction guarantee go to myundes.com
that's meundies.com
t-i-m
we're gonna wrap it up in a little bit
here but i think we've kind of solved it
i mean i think we solved it dude uh body
armor fashion lines we gotta arm up yeah
uh we gotta have these schools
completely armed everyone armed all the
time including the kids watching each
other taking all these factors into
account yeah and then you need uh
surveillance systems too you need
surveillance at all times yeah at all
times yeah and uh yeah and that'll keep
everyone free well at least it'll give
pedophiles some jobs while they're doing
some good why not watch the kids here's
a crazy idea yeah pedophiles
outside the schools with guns
the pedophiles care about the kids
nobody loves them more pedophiles care
about the kids they can protect the
schools with guns nobody is going to
care for the world what about an army of
pedophiles around the school with guns i
love it
solved
give pedophiles guns yeah let them arm
the schools yeah and maybe uh we go back
to castles where there's like a boat
around it's not a bad idea to just have
a like put schools in places
geographically that are harder to get to
so all the kids are in school you bring
the draw bridge up right lava i think
the honest answer is also like why have
schools when you could just send kids to
work houses and work
that's probably why this is happening
there was no shootings when there were
workhouses in london let's get these
kids back to work cleaning chimneys at
four
it's a it's a good idea yeah i mean
again folks this is you know it's a
you know
it's an issue but it's not that big of a
deal it's not it's not a big deal not as
big of a deal as a lot of other things
yes there's a lot of other problems that
are a bigger deal what do ricky gervais
say there's whole kinds of what ricky
gervais say is a big big problem i don't
think it's a big you know listen people
are gonna die yeah and some of them are
gonna be young yeah
what are you gonna do there's nothing
are you gonna ban child death it's
really not as big of a deal as are you
gonna ban child death you can't ban
child death yeah and you know it's like
we we're all really more concerned about
what's gonna happen in this verdict with
johnny depp and amber hurt oh god
what's a bigger deal what's the bigger
deal that's right what do people care
about more really yeah i think they care
more about that well it's more fun it's
more fun this is very depressing with
the kids and the the people always
getting shot it's very depressing yeah
it is fun a fake faked i needed i called
it i called it months ago i said we
needed a trial
to get us out of this i said
maybe kanye would like kill kim and pete
or something i said we needed a trial
yeah to get us out of the coven malays
and it was deaf heard and i didn't even
know
uh amber heard breaks down on stan i'm
getting thousands of death threats and
here shed get more
um but you know i said we needed a trial
i was correct we absolutely need a trial
we need trials on every channel we need
uh prank shows on every channel yeah and
we need people inside please don't leave
your house ever yeah at all just watch
this new form of entertainment it's
great because it's like it's like soccer
there's very few commercial breaks it
goes for 20 hours yeah this is the
longest trial that's great i mean this
shooting will be out of the news in an
hour
this won't even be relevant when it's
released on saturday in two days this
episode won't be there'll be another
shooting by then yeah but this depth
thing has gone on for as long as i can
remember i think it's six weeks i feel
like i've grown up with these people
yeah i care more about them than i do my
own family yeah and it's not even close
yes i care more about amber hurd and
johnny depp than these kids that got
shot because i've been with them longer
it's just on more it's great yeah and i
mean it's just it's just what it is and
it's the only thing left really that
hasn't been done right it's like uh
trials yeah celebrities that are real
they're drug addicts they beat each
other up yeah for your entertainment and
you know what's fun about it they're
rich so there's butlers and maids and
nannies and assistants and like weird
types of things and there's coachella in
the hills in australia and we're in
we're in italy or whatever they're doing
and they're you know it's fun to hear
about somebody getting beaten
in a nice area it's for once it's a good
it's a good time to be a body language
expert yeah they're really they're doing
real well they're doing real well
they're
providing a lot of commentary for this
yeah well i mean folks we've come up
with the solutions i don't know what you
want me to do i mean you know
unfortunately this is what happens you
can homeschool your kids and you can
shoot them yeah don't go out but it's
not just school so don't go outside well
you don't need to yeah with an instacart
and postmates yeah you don't really need
no no truly now you don't need to go out
don't need to be outside you don't need
to if you go to a national park you get
abducted if you go to the grocery store
you make a shot in the face
you don't need to go outside there's
you have streaming services you have
people that are willing to brave the
elements to bring you nachos and they're
gonna get killed
so at the end of the day there's no real
reason you need to leave your house it's
not a big deal everything should be like
going to
the airport there should be
checkpoints
and metal detectors every you shouldn't
nobody should have their shoes on ever
there's one safe place in america
there's one safe place in america
and it's austin
texas paradise so if you want to live in
a place where was this shooting how far
away from austin uh so it was 30 minutes
or 90 miles west of san antonio so
that's about three hours i guess okay
yeah yeah but now google austin shooting
i bet yeah i bet nothing comes up let's
see no austin i bet nothing comes out
austin's just weird at news here it's
all gonna be
what happened here
man shot dead by officers after he
allegedly pointed a gun at people from
his truck
that was 17 hours ago and dead after
opening fire on officers from pickup
truck in southeast austin
this is the same thing
yeah teen arrested after shooting death
in south austin parking lot outside la
fitness that was three days ago half of
deadliest u.s shootings were in texas oh
it's weird it's really great you know
it's weird when you go
it's not a great
it's not great it's weird when you go to
like the uh the
the uh very like liberal i guess as far
as right gun gun laws go like you can
meaning you can have a gun you go to
those places but they have signs at all
the places where you go that's don't
bring your gun in here right you're like
wait a second i thought i was in north
carolina what do you mean i can't bring
my gun to the opera right
why can i not have my gun at the
opponent
you notice that all the stores have
places uh you no guns no guns you're
like dude aren't we in north what's the
point yeah of having the gun if i can't
bring it inside well here's the deal i
mean we've been a bunch of buffoons and
goofballs but my suggestion to everyone
with children is to just [ __ ] not get
so attached
my name is tim dillon this special the
special that we're talking about is
called mom love yeah and we need a lot
less of mom and dad love yeah
janice pappas is on youtube right now
mom love it's a full hour special very
very funny
um and my special coming out soon we
just got an offer today so it might not
be on youtube we'll see
um support the sponsors of the show if
you enjoy the content we really do
appreciate people get mad at the ad
reads you go they're not funny anymore
well here's reality folks some of these
companies are just paying too much money
for us to be funny and they don't
understand that if we're funnier more
people
would actually buy the products so if
these companies are listening uh the
reality is if we're able to do funny ads
people buy the product more i always
fight for the funny ads and there are
some companies that will still let us do
the funny ads but some won't and you
know what do you want me to do not earn
money they won't even give us the this
is how dumb people are people are like
isn't it enough to patreon and they're
not southern because the southern people
understand i should have a fiefdom but
it's probably people are like don't you
unders patreon's enough why do you even
have ads that go because we want more
than less money it's america also dummy
if i there would be no ads like for
example there would never have been ads
and they won't give i won't have ads and
i won't do any of the ads like if i
don't do them the way they want me to do
them i just won't have them right
every now and then a company will let us
do a funny ad yeah yeah now the the
problem is i've explained to these
companies that funny ads are actually
better because they're longer and people
don't skip them and they actually buy
the product
but the problem is a lot of companies
now are getting a little upset
at some of these funny ads you know
what do you want me to i don't know what
to do but these products are still great
what do we have the watch and the the
underwear the underwear on it we have
athletic greens i mean uh you're not
gonna buy on it
these are great companies
on it was a supplement company started
by popular podcaster mark maron
these are great companies and i'm
telling you right now if you miss out on
a box of awesome are they still with us
they're still with us yeah yeah
if you miss out on a box of awesome
which is they'll give you a little
wooden box with a uh you know like a
pipe and a couple of sticks of dynamite
if you miss out on that
your fault your problem
giannis are you promoting anything where
are you gonna be tell them where to find
you god help the special please just go
watch watch this goddamn special you're
gonna love it it's a good hour the the
people who seem to really like it people
are enjoying it people the people want
it yeah so just go watch that listen to
my podcast people wanted long days with
giannis pappas we're putting all the
links in the description
it'll be out this uh saturday janice bob
is on twitter science journalist hee haw
long day's podcast go watch his special
uh
as always we have a patreon right now
with uh out right now with sal
from the impractical jokers which is
funny and um
[Music]
what else we got cooking what else are
you what are you doing now oh you're
you're on the road ugh you have dates to
perform i have two dates i i have uh if
you haven't seen me i'm uh
friday saturday and sunday i'm at the
funny boat in richmond virginia god help
me god help me and uh two shows friday
two shows saturday one show sunday i
mean who's buying tickets to this i
think that's it's memorial day but
anyway comment will be great
six into the 18 san jose absolute last
dates probably like had less headlining
dates for like six months uh minimum
probably and then uh i'll be just doing
spots out there but you know
get it while the getting is good folks i
don't know what to tell you oh i got one
um if you listen to this i'm saturday
this shot
in uh i'm in uh newport rhode island at
the jane pickens
go fly to see me in richmond
jane pickett's theater may 28th newport
rhode island part of the rogue island
comedy festival doug key great guy
september 9th through 10th uncle
vinnie's in port well that's a little
bit out isn't this out there i'm taking
a little time off i gotta write a new
act you gotta write a new act and you
have a child i have a child and you need
to train i need to train her in military
tactical defense yeah and she's greek
she'll take to it she'll take to it very
well she'll take to it she'll have a
ar15 and a full beard when she's five
absolutely it's her gonna be her
two-year-old uh birthday present
good night everyone and good luck